this was a low-key first appearance by
Ani Arnold on the day she received the
highest honor in literature A Brief wave
outside her home in a Paris suburb just
after she had been named the 2022
Laureate by the Nobel Committee in
Stockholm
the Nobel Prize in literature for 2022
is awarded to the French author
for the courage and clinical Acuity with
which she uncovers the roots
estrangements and Collective restraints
of personal memory her books such as a
man's place and happening deal with her
working-class Roots relationships with
her parents and an illegal abortion she
had in the 1960s
I will continue to fight until my last
breath so that women can remain free to
choose to be mothers or not because
contraception the right to abortion are
the Matrix of women's freedom
her willingness to deal with difficult
subjects was one attribute cited by the
Nobel committee she's so Frank and
direct and honest in her way of
expression and also that she writes
about themes and topics that no one else
touches on you know that she is she
she's courageous woman and that we have
also in our motivation
I know it's just the 17th woman to
receive this prize alongside 102 men
but the door is being opened to more
female writers
the Swedish Academy has given itself the
task of awarding Nobel prizes to a wider
range of authors fewer to the Western
World and more to women
the statistics historically appear
catastrophic but we can't put right what
happened in the 1900s there weren't many
female researchers then but now we're on
the way to a balance and we don't have
to strain ourselves it's natural to go
in that direction our nor can now expect
to sell more of her books at least here
in Stockholm where there was a rush on
for the works of last year's winner
tanzania's Abdul razak gona
sales go up well you could say a
thousand fold because they're often
unknown authors who win so it's from 0
to 100 in orders as soon as it's
announced at age 82 elnor is the first
French woman to receive this prize
rewarded at last 48 years after her
debut novel
Polaris Al Jazeera Stockholm